[Music]
and we've got heading fopa with us from
the hamburg institute of international
economics mr purple would you also
describe turkey as a dependable business
partner yeah i would do so because
turkey is still from a strategic point
very important and interesting
economy and turkey is well integrated
into global cross-border supply chains
so turkey is important and that's why
capital is still there
why the knee-jerk reaction though money
being pulled out all of a sudden and
then
a month later being reinvested yeah so
capital is is the most mobile factor of
production
much more mobile than than labor so
that's why financial markets are a good
predictor or indicator for the political
and economic situation economy so that's
why there was a was a withdrawal of
capital and now we have a reversal back
capital back to back to turkey now not
calling turkey a dictatorship but
it has a very different set up to many
democratic countries
what does it mean for investors
a democracy is a democracy a safer place
to do
business because it's a a looser place
politically i guess or
or or is a near dictatorship or a
dictatorship
a safer place actually it's it's
stability that matters for for investors
to to decide where to place investments
or portfolio investments we have to
distinguish between portfolio investment
short-term capital and long-term capital
fdi foreign direct investment so
different kind of reasons to to go into
a country and we see all over the world
that especially for emerging
market economies uh the withdrawal the
yeah
to go out of out of a country makes
countries very vulnerable towards
political and economic sharks
what about the lyra it fell by seven
percent after the coup attempt
if you compare that to the brexit
the pound fell a lot more than that what
does that tell us
i think the brexit is a more paradigm or
change in there's a lot of or huge
uncertainty coming along with the brexit
and nobody knows how the future will be
like and that's why
there was a kind of
yeah you can say currency crisis a kind
of hurting behavior so be the first out
of the market
so all up would you say that money has
no conscience
yeah i would say so and we we live in a
world where we have a world economy with
a lot of crisis
and it's a it's a disorder it's a
feeling like the world is in disorder
and that's uh then the question comes up
where is your capital your investments
safe and uh you you're looking for
stability rather than for democracy or
freedom well stability isn't something
that europe can offer at the moment
there it's one crisis after the next
even terror attacks um
what makes investors keep coming back to
europe then well there was a
disappointment uh given the high
expectations uh with regard to emerging
market economies now we have
a situation where capital is going back
to
to
the more
developed economies like the us like
like europe where
um the the conditions the circumstances
are more stable and that's why we have a
we have a um yeah capital back from the
emerging market economies back to back
to the more developed economies thanks
thank you very much for coming in today
welcome